and so he can date someone else and have
sex because if you're gonna Court me
we're not gonna have sex because I'm not
gonna just sleep with you you've just
gone back on your statement yeah but
then like why why wouldn't he just I'm
trying to answer your question he's
saying why have you gone back earlier
because you said that someone can date
you and have sex but you're saying
me in general okay
you can't date me and just have sex and
it and I will hope that one day it
releases the relationship right that
can't happen respectfully respectfully
forget you for a second
can date and it can lead to a
relationship for other women but the
reason why I don't think that's right is
because that can is not a hundred
percent so I don't think it's right it's
not 100 that's going to lead to a
relationship to marriage yeah yeah it's
not 100 of the dating is going to lead
100 to marriage to anything serious
foreign